[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hi, guys.
Thank you everybody
so much for coming.
We have two really exciting
guests with us today,
and I think some
of their stories
are really going
to give all of us
a little extra something
to think about today.
So, I have Coss Marte
and Shane Ennover.
So before we really
get into everything
we're going to discuss today,
I want to actually play
a little clip for everybody.
So Coss actually had an
experience with BuzzFeed,
where they took a couple
guys that were not inmates
to a prison and actually had
them work out there for a week.
And I think that'll really
frame up the conversation
and give everyone a sense
of what ConBody really is.
Can you guys cue the tape?
[VIDEO PLAYING]
- Start off with the
regular jumping jacks.
Don't pass out yet.
Sideways, Rocco.
Let's go.
- So the guy who is training
us this week is Coss.
Coss is relentless.
- You know how to count to ten?
You're going to fuck up today.
- He's so understated
when he's talking to you.
As soon as class gets
started, he's a psycho.
That's five laps, Rocco?
No it ain't.
Don't cheat me.
You're going to do five laps.
- I've seen him in
the men's fitness,
and you know I
was like, Oh yeah,
I'm going to start
doing this stuff.
I've been doing it
before, but it really
encourages me when I see him.
I was like, He did
it, I can do it too.
- The ConBody workout is
insanity times 10 with a prison
kick into it.
Within five days of this
workout they'll probably
lose five to 10 pounds.
It's all body weight.
I actually developed this whole
routine in my prison cell.
I started selling
drugs on a milk crate
and I grew it out to a
multimillion dollar drug
business, and I was sentenced
to seven years in prison.
I came up with the
idea of ConBody
while I was in
solitary confinement.
Now I have over 7,000 clients.
- One, two, three.
- God.
Anything bad I ever ate,
I regret it right now.
- You ain't even getting low.
You ain't even getting low.
- I'm just trying to
survive with my breathing.
- Lets go all the way back.
All the way back.
They're waiting for you.
- My arms just couldn't do it.
This is non-stop.
- Bring it back, come on.
Come on.
Let's go, all the way back.
All the way back.
Let's go.
Push it.
It's almost over,
it's almost over.
One lap.
Give him a hand.
[CHEERING]
- Let's go.
Last one happened.
Let's go.
[END PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER: So that's just
a little something,
I think, what people
can expect when
they go into ConBody studio.
COSS MARTE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: But Coss, let's
talk a little bit more
about how this all started
and what actually landed you
in prison.
COSS MARTE: Yeah.
I'm just going to
ask a quick question
to everybody in the audience.
Who here has been so excited to
go on a job interview before?
Nobody?
You hate Google?
Well.
Fuck this shit.
Now imagine yourself going
through a job interview
and now having that door
slammed in your face
when he came to Google.
This happened to
me over 100 times
when I was released
in 2013, when
I was released from prison.
And every time I went
to apply for a job
I had to check off the check
mark and say I had a felony.
And every time I went to any
convenience store, any clothing
store in midtown, they
said, you have a felony?
And I'll see the
reaction in their face
or they'll look
at the application
and they'll just
put it to the side.
And it was just discouraging and
frustrating for the most part.
And that's where I came up with
ConBody, out of desperation.
I had the idea when I was
in prison to start ConBody.
This is all derived from my
whole experience growing up.
I was born and raised
in the Lower East
Side of New York City.
On Broome and Eldridge is where
I started selling drugs at,
where ConBody is today.
My mom immigrated from
the Dominican Republic
when she was six months
pregnant with me.
And when she came
we had very little.
We lived on my Aunt's couch.
I would go to work
with her, because she
would sneak me under
her sewing machine
and just babysit me there.
It was sad because
I wanted more.
And I'd see the other kids
in school with other things
and when the teacher
asked us what
do you want to be
when you grow up,
I always said I
wanted to be rich
because I felt like that was
the way I can escape poverty.
And the first opportunity
that I became rich
was from the world of drugs.
I'd seen all the guys on the
corner who were selling drugs
on my block and they had
cars and money and everything
I really wanted.
And at 11 I started smoking
weed and started following
in their footsteps,
became somebody
that was looking out for them.
And then I began
selling for them
at 13 and from there
it quickly escalated.
And my good friend and
I, Joey [INAUDIBLE], we
changed the way we sold drugs.
I'm going to teach you how
to sell drugs right now,
so take notes if you
want to quit Google
and hit the streets.
But no, what we
did was we stopped
hanging around in the corner.
We used to wear big jeans and
very stereotypical Jordans.
A typical drug dealer that
was selling on the corner.
And we would get stopped
every single day by cops
and they would harass
us and lock us up.
I've been in and out about
10 times for BS charges
and so we came up with
an idea of wearing suits,
going up to people
that started changing
the neighborhood because
it was like really getting
gentrified at the time.
This was the early 2000s.
And we made 10,000 business
cards and we went up
to everybody who
looked like they
used drugs and our pitch line
was like, Do you want blow?
And they were like, What the
hell are you talking about?
But it was pretty crazy.
From there it started
escalating and by the age of 19
I was making over
$2 million a year.
I had over 20 people
working for me.
I had this whole operation
delivery service.
It went down at 23
when federal agents
came knocking on my door.
They found everything and they
took everything away from me.
And that's when I was faced
with seven years in prison
At this point, I
went into a prison
and doctors told me that I
could die because of my health
issues.
And this is the first
time I really found out
that I had any health issues.
The doctors said that my
cholesterol levels were so high
that I probably could die from a
heart attack within five years.
And they're saying being
sentenced to seven years
and having five years
to live in prison,
I told myself I was not going
to die in this situation.
Especially because I
had a two-year-old son
when I went in.
Now he's nine years old.
Yeah I went in there
and I basically
started moving as soon
as they told me that I
had all these health issues.
So I went back to
my cell and started
doing dips and push-ups.
It was crazy.
I worked out for about five
minutes and then passed out.
And then I just sat there
on my bed and I was like,
I need to start doing
something with my life,
start really taking
advantage of this time.
I went out to the yard and
I started running the yard.
And I was the only
person running the yard
and then going back to
my unit and working out.
And I started working out
like two to three hours a day,
and from there I
helped over 20 inmates
lose was over 1,000
pounds combined.
So I took that same program that
I started in the prison yard
and I set out.
This is what I really
wanted to duplicate.
But I didn't think
about that while I
was doing it in the yard.
It was towards the end
of my prison experience
where I had a
spiritual awakening.
I was walking towards
the medical unit,
I was in another
facility, and this officer
placed me on the wall.
They do random
searches and Shane
knows they just really abuse
the way they search you.
And they put you on
a wall leaning down,
and this guy started touching
me in uncomfortable places.
And I moved a little
bit and this officer
smacked me in the back of
my head really, really hard,
and I dropped down
to the ground.
And at the time I was wearing
glasses and they fell.
And I went to pick them up
and as soon as I got up,
I turned around on
him and he thought
I was going to charge him.
So he quickly pressed this
button in his walkie talkie.
As soon as they press that
button, it's called The Pen,
you just need and
brace for impact
because dozens of
officers come to the scene
and they just beat
the crap out of you.
And that's exactly
what they did.
They just stomped on me and
they cuffed me and threw me
in the cell.
And at this time
I was devastated
because I've told my son that I
was coming home in two months.
I told my son that I was
coming home in two months
and I lied to him.
I saw him in the
visiting room and I only
had a couple of months left.
It was about that
weekend when I saw him.
He was excited.
And that situation
happened and now I'm
sitting in this
prison cell thinking
how am I going to get
out of this situation?
This guy said I charged him and
I was going to attempt assault
and was pressing all
these crazy charges that
were on untruthful.
I broke down.
I had nothing in
that prison cell
except for the tools that they
gave me, which were paper, pen
and an envelope.
And I wrote out a letter.
I sat down on the little table
there and I wrote out a letter.
I was basically
explaining to my family
that I'm not coming
home, I fucked up again,
forget about me.
I'm probably going to
do about three more
years behind the situation.
And then I enclosed
the letter and then
I realized I didn't have a stamp
to send out this letter with.
So at this moment I get
even more frustrated
and I want to just bang
my head in the cell.
I don't know what to do.
The cell is about 105 degrees,
there's no AC, no fan.
And it was just a crazy
moment in my life.
And
Then about a week later my
sister writes me a letter
and she tells me to
Psalm 91 from the Bible.
My sister is like
Mother Teresa's child.
She's like, hallelujah, amen.
One of those people.
Nothing against her, but she
told me to read Psalm 91.
And I was like Hell no,
I'm not reading this shit.
I don't believe in God.
It's all a hoax.
And all I had was this
Bible that she gave me
in the beginning of my
prison sentence and my cell.
And I'm there, and
I took that letter
that she wrote me and I threw
it in the corner of my cell.
And I just laid back in
the corner of my cell.
But after a couple of days,
probably about two or three
days, I decided to
open up the Bible
because there was
nothing else to do.
I was in 24 hour lockdown.
And I opened up the Bible
and I turned to the pages
that she told me
to read, Psalm 91.
And as soon as I
started reading it,
a stamp fell out of my Bible.
And it was the
stamp that I needed
to send out this ten
page letter to my family
that I've written to tell
them that I'm in trouble
and to explain to them
the whole situation.
And as soon as that stamp fell
out something came to body.
There were chills
running down my spine
and I felt like there was
something bigger than myself.
It really humbled me.
And I began praying
for the first time.
And I started feeling a lot of
regret for what I was doing.
I began reading the
Bible from front to back.
For the first time I started
believing that what I was doing
was wrong, selling
drugs in prison,
selling drugs in the streets
and affecting so many people.
And then I started realizing
that these people have families
just like my family was
affected by the drug industry.
I began praying.
I started asking God like, How
can I give back to society?
And how can I repay for all
the wrongs that I've done?
And I just put two
and two together
and I came up with the
idea of ConBody there.
I figured that the
guys that I was already
helping in the prison yard I was
actually doing something right
and I was giving back.
And I said this is
what I wanted to do,
so I wrote out using
a long sheet of paper
that they give you and the
side of the Bible as my ruler.
I started making a spreadsheet
of like every work out,
my whole calendar
when I came home.
I had the time to do it,
so I put all that together.
I came out of that cell and I
was partnered up with this guy,
I had a bunky, and as soon as
I step up to my bunky's unit
I see him reading the Bible.
And I was like, Oh, shit.
I want to tell
this guy my story.
I tell him my story and he's
like, How much time did you
do in the box?
He just looked at
me like I was crazy.
So I was like, I'm not telling
anyone this story ever again.
But I'm here today.
I'm at Google
telling you my story.
I've been fortunate enough to
travel the world now and share
my testimonial, share my story.
I finally served an extra
year behind the situation,
so I was released
one year after that.
And I came home and I started
doing it in the local park.
I was back in the
same neighborhood,
my mom still lives in a tenement
apartment on Rivington Street,
rent controlled.
You must be jealous,
because you can't afford it.
But yeah, I get back to
that, living on our couch.
And every day I would wake up
and just go out to the park
and start working out.
I take out this piece of pipe
and stuck it between gates
and started doing pull-up
bar training there.
And from there it just
started escalating.
From there I started
renting out ballet studios.
The ballet studios started
getting really, really packed.
And then we started working out
of a prison behind a preschool.
And the whole idea
was that I really
wanted to build a gym
that looked like a prison.
People asked me, why
did you want do that?
First of all it was a great
branding and marketing
opportunity.
No, but seriously, the
reason why I did that
was because I came home
and I was looking for jobs.
I finally found an
internship that I
was getting a minimum wage for.
At this internship
we were helping
people that were on public
assistance find employment
and I was a resume writer.
I didn't know how
to type for shit,
but I told them I knew how to
type 40, 50 words per minute
on my resume.
And then eventually I was
like, [TICK TICK TICK].
So then I got there.
I'm better now.
So we started
working there and we
were working with people
that were formerly released.
My employees were not
former convicts or ex-cons,
so behind the scenes
they were discriminating
against the people
that were coming in.
They were always
saying, oh, this person
is going to come back.
We're tired of
seeing this person.
Blah, blah, blah.
And behind my head I'm
getting so frustrated
because they don't know
my background story.
I'm like, you don't even
know what we went through.
I feel like I'm a real product
of the school to prison
pipeline.
And then one day I
really got frustrated.
And finally when I had
ConBody fully up and running
I told them my story.
And they were like, what?
You were in prison?
And it really changed
their whole views.
I told them what I was
doing and now they're
extremely receptive of the
fact that formerly incarcerated
people can change their lives
if we're given the right tools
and the right opportunities.
So I came home
and left that job.
I started doing ConBody
and I was doing it
by myself for a while.
Then I met another trainer and
then I bumped into this guy.
We were both locked
up in the same unit.
We were in Greene
Correctional Facility.
What brought us together was
a phenomenon that God made.
We call it [? Babashrugu, ?]
it was our code word
for marijuana.
So we were actually
smoking weed.
SPEAKER: Where most
love stories begin.
COSS MARTE: We're smoking weed
in the prison yard and showers
It was a crazy,
crazy connection.
And when he came home we
connected through Facebook.
We connect and I told him, you
have to come out and check out
what I'm doing.
And I think he already knew
what we were doing before.
He had just seen the
Facebook posts and stuff.
He came out and he was like,
I want to be a part of this.
So it just became an
amazing opportunity
to reconnect people that
I've been incarcerated with
and people that been trying
to readapt back to society.
And now today our
whole mission is
to hire as many formerly
incarcerated individuals
as possible to teach
our fitness classes.
We're based on the
Lower East Side,
like I said before, in the
same corner where I was selling
drugs at Broome and Eldridge.
And it's just been an
amazing experience.
With BuzzFeed, we went to a
California city-state prison
and I trained 60
inmates in there.
And these inmates,
they were tatted up
and they look scary
and this and that.
And when I walk in there
with the BuzzFeed employees
they quickly hid in the
closet, and they were like,
oh we need to store stuff.
I'm like, get the fuck
out of the closet.
These people want to see you.
They shook their hand and
it was just so intimidated.
And I had to step
to the side, and I
was like, these people
are actually humans.
You know, they made
a mistake and you
need to respect the fact
that they're still people.
And that's what I'm
trying to do is break down
the stereotypes between formerly
incarcerated individuals
and young professionals.
SPEAKER: I actually
think ConBody,
that that's one of
the reasons that I got
so excited about the studio.
Something we were
talking about is
that there's a lot of boutique
fitness studios in New York
City.
And when you walk in they're
all really expensive,
and they're all very
exclusive, but you don't really
feel like you're part of it.
COSS MARTE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: And I do think
walking into ConBody,
you guys make everybody
feel like they're
a part of the crew, like
we're all in this together.
It just makes it
a family, and it
makes it a really good
workout experience.
And I mean, apart from the fact
that you guys kick everyone's
asses who walk in there.
SHANE ENNOVER: Well when
you, just in general,
when you're locked up with
someone like Coss and I were,
you become very close to them.
Because you and the person
with you are all you guys got.
That's it.
So you become very close people.
You form these
good relationships.
And you're not
actually locked up,
but we kind of give
off that persona.
So you actually still
get that intimacy,
I guess you would say.
Whereas you wouldn't get it in
some big name gym or big name
studio.
We always say hi
when people walk in.
We try to start a conversation.
How was your day?
How did you get here?
And you feel at home.
I feel at home when I'm there.
SPEAKER: And that's really
how you and I got to talking.
because you walk up to every
single person after class
and you ask them
how they're doing
and you're very open
with your story.
And I think your
story is interesting
because when you
first told me, I
thought it was something
out of a movie.
So let's tell everybody
what your background is
and what got you
to where you are.
SHANE ENNOVER: My story
is a little different.
It's actually kind of
the complete opposite end
of the spectrum
as far as Coss's.
Because I'm not from the
city, I'm from Long Island.
And I didn't sell
drugs, I did drugs.
And it pretty much started
when I was like 13 years old.
My sister's ex-boyfriend
moved in with us at the time
and he smoked weed.
So, of course, I thought he
was like the coolest thing
ever so we start
smoking weed together.
And that was the
first time I ever
really got introduced to drugs.
I never really had
a weed problem,
but eventually I
had broken my leg
and they gave me some Vicodin.
And I liked the Vicodin.
Who doesn't like Vicodin?
I'm sorry.
But I was very
young at the time.
I was like 15, 16 years old
and very impressionable.
Then I found out that all my
friends were doing Vicodin,
they're all doing really heavy
painkillers like Oxycontin
and things like that.
And eventually I was
like, you know what?
Why not?
Let's just do it.
Why not do it?
It came to the point where
there was nothing available,
and we all got very sick.
And we didn't understand
why we were sick,
but we were withdrawing.
And we didn't
actually understand
what withdrawing meant until
we actually looked it up.
We were like, oh, shit.
This is what this is?
How long this going to last?
We couldn't just like
Google something back then.
We didn't know
what was going on.
So eventually we found out.
We did our research, but
we didn't really even know
how long it was going on.
All we cared about
was getting better,
and that's all you care about
when you're doing drugs.
So at this point I'm doing
Oxycontin and heroin.
And probably like a year after
that I started doing cocaine.
And I was doing a bunch of
other party drugs, like ecstasy.
I did acid a whole
bunch of times.
But it was just
drugs, drugs, drugs.
That was what I did.
It was a full time job.
I woke up, if I didn't have
money, I had to get money.
If I had the money, I
was getting the drugs.
If I had the drugs and
the money I was good.
I could live a normal life.
But first things first,
I've got to get high.
SPEAKER: So let's talk about
how you had to get the money.
SHANE ENNOVER: The
first big thing
I used to do, I was
working at a bagel place.
I was actually stealing like
$200, $300 a day from them.
If I can get more,
I can get more but.
That alone right
there plus my paycheck
would be enough to
support a good habit.
But I quit that job to get
another job at another deli
and I got fired at that job.
So now I have no money.
I owe my drug dealer money.
I am about to go through
withdrawal because I barely
have any drugs left.
And he actually used
to give me little jobs,
and what I mean by
jobs is certain houses
to rob, people he knew.
And he said, listen, I
want you to go in there.
All I want is--
all I want are the
guns and the jewelry.
Anything else in
there you can have.
If you find money, if you
find a TV, appliances,
anything like that,
you can have all that.
All I want are the
guns and the jewelry.
And I'd come out of houses
with these gigantic AK-47s
and shotguns and
the most fabulous
looking jewelry
you'll ever find.
That's all he wanted.
OK.
So I owed him some money at the
time and I'm like 17 years old.
This was 2006.
So he calls he's like, Shane,
I hadn't heard from me you
a while.
I was like, yeah,
because I owe you money.
I'm not going to call you up,
get more things on credit,
you know that's just stupid.
I was like, you have
any work for me?
He says, give me one second,
let me call you back.
So he calls me back, he says,
listen, I'm outside your house.
Come get in the car.
So I go in the car, and there
is a woman in the front seat.
And she's like, Shane.
He's like, all right, so.
I was like, Well, what,
do you got work for me?
He says, yeah, so you're
going to rob a bank.
I was like, what?
I'm not robbing a bank, dude.
Turn this car right back around.
Like, I'll get a job and
I'll get you your money.
I'm not robing no fucking bank.
Like, that's not happening.
So they're like, oh,
no, listen, listen.
So the girl was
actually telling me
that she was a bank
teller at the time
and they get robbed
on a monthly basis.
Like it was just a thing.
OK, bank got robbed.
So what?
And I know probably everybody's
thinking right now that I'm
going in there with
AK-47s and president masks
and like, everybody get
the fuck on the floor.
No.
That's not how it went down.
Like, at all.
I was like 120 pounds
soaking wet, if that.
A very skinny little
kid going in there
passing them a note
saying, this is a robbery.
Give me the big bills first.
That's how it went down.
I passed them a
little piece of paper.
I said, this is a robbery.
Give me the big bills first,
because they'll start handing
you singles and change rolls.
Don't make any sudden movements.
Don't call anybody over.
And you have to say,
definitely say, no money wraps.
Because the minute they put
the money in the drawer,
they unwrap it.
If it's wrapped that
means it's a dye pack.
I've gotten a dye pack before.
It's not fun.
Actually, it's like those smoke
bombs, like you light them up?
It's like that but with ink.
And I got it one time and it
was in my pocket and I heard it.
It was actually ticking.
Like, [TICKING NOISES].
And I heard it.
I was like, that's weird.
As soon as I took it out of my
pocket, it just starts going.
I just threw it on
the ground, but there
was somebody in there.
So, yeah, it was a big scene.
So I pass the teller the note
and they give me the money.
So eventually I
agreed to do it and I
got hooked up with
a friend of mine
that had already did a bank.
So now we're full fledged bank
robbers, as silly as it sounds.
SPEAKER: Actually, you were
called "The Serial Bank
Robber."
SHANE ENNOVER: So
News 12 is like, what
this city would have, New
York 1, their a local thing.
I was actually dubbed
"The Pleasant Bandit."
Which is pretty funny,
because I guess I was nice.
SPEAKER: Because
you said please.
SHANE ENNOVER: I said,
please, I said thank you,
because I wanted to make
it seem to anybody that
was right next to me that
nothing else was going
on but making a transaction.
I would actually come in
there with open envelopes
and I would take
the note out of that
just to make it look like,
if anybody else would see me,
all they would see
is, oh wait, he's just
like looking at
a bank statement,
or whatever the case may be.
I tried to make it as
official as possible.
So I did six banks.
After the sixth one I realized
what the fuck I was doing,
I guess, and I checked
myself into rehab.
But two weeks
after that, the guy
that I was doing it with
it, he turned himself in.
And in turning himself
in, he turned me in.
Now I'm locked up.
I had never been arrested.
I had never even seen
the cop car, nothing.
I've never been arrested.
So, I'm on what's called
"The Tiers" or cellblocks,
and I'm getting beat
up a lot because that's
how the adolescent tiers are.
They're just wild.
Like two, three, four fights
a day on average, if that.
It's just it's wild.
Has anybody ever seen or read
the book "Lord of the Flies"?
It's like that.
It's just madness, chaos.
And the cops don't care.
They can't control us because
we're just these kids.
You can't stop those
fights, because there are so
many gangs.
So I was just getting beat up
so much, because I'm so weak.
I don't know how to fight.
I was this hippie.
Like, yeah man, whats up, dude?
I'm from Long Island.
I was from the suburbs.
I didn't do those
kind of things.
My family was well off.
I was, I guess you could
call it, upper middle class.
So I never had to deal
with this kind of stuff.
Even though I was doing
drugs, I wasn't really like
in the streets, though.
So I was getting
really tired of just
getting beat up all day long.
Because you get picked on.
They just see you, they know you
can't fight, they'll try you.
And I was fighting,
that's not the problem.
So eventually I was like,
something's got to change.
So I asked someone
about working out.
Maybe there's something I could
do, easy, to start me off.
I remember I went
to my cell, and I
started doing dips, bench dips.
Where you just put
your hands behind you,
so you go up and down
like that with the arms.
As a matter of fact, no.
I tried to do a set
of push-ups, first.
I remember getting up off the
floor after doing like three
and gasping, dying, for air.
So I was like, Let
me try some of these.
So I tried the dips and
I realized I could do it.
Oh wow, this is cool.
So then I keep doing
more and more dips
and I'm realizing I'm
getting a little stronger.
I started to try to do
push-ups and I'm like, wow,
I can do push-ups now.
Then I start asking people
for advice on how to fight,
so now I'm actually
winning fights.
Now my confidence
is through the roof.
And I gained 40 pounds
in like two months,
so I'm a lot bigger, I'm a
lot stronger, I can fight now.
I just felt really
good about myself.
But then I'm realizing all
the working out I'm doing,
I feel healthier.
Has anybody ever-- how can I put
this-- gone on a real partying
binge?
When you're younger you're just
drinking every single night,
nonstop.
SPEAKER: I believe the
kids call it a "bender."
SHANE ENNOVER: Yes, exactly.
"The kids."
And then right after that
you're like, you know what?
Something's got to change,
and you stop drinking.
And then you actually start
working out and eating healthy,
and you're like, wow!
Yeah, I could do this.
This is good.
I'm going to live
like this from now on.
That's how I felt. I was
like, wow, this is great.
I can actually like,
live a good life.
So I'm working--
SPEAKER: Just to
clarify, that's how
you were feeling
because that is what
was affecting your withdrawals.
SHANE ENNOVER: Yes.
SPEAKER: The fitness.
SHANE ENNOVER: So I went through
the immediate withdrawals,
but that's the
physical portion of it.
Then you have the
mental withdrawals.
You feel better, but
if you do the drugs
you get that fresh high, and
there ain't nothing better
than that fresh high.
You haven't done
drugs in a while.
You're not withdrawing.
It's not like you're doing the
drug as the job just to live,
you're doing the drug
to get high again.
And there's nothing
better than that.
But to get that out of
my head I was working out
and it felt so good.
I felt like a normal person.
Fast forward, I ended
up getting sentenced
to one to three years.
I did one year out of that.
I made my first parole board.
And my family was
there the whole time.
They saw my progression,
how I got my GED
while I was there because I
had dropped out of high school.
SPEAKER: And Coss
actually mentioned
you had really good grades
while you were there.
SHANE ENNOVER: Eventually,
when I did go upstate,
we met in the college
program, I had a 3.8 GPA,
which is pretty good for someone
who was a high school dropout.
So, backtrack, I got
locked up for a year.
And when I came home you
couldn't tell me anything.
If anybody looked at
me I was like, well,
you don't know where I've been.
You don't know what I just had
to go through, fighting to eat.
It's a strange feeling when you
have to fight to actually eat.
Literally like a caveman.
It's completely different.
Plus, my dad got
me a job because he
was one of these big wigs
at a nursing home company
he was working at
and I play music.
So my boy got me a
job teaching music.
So at that time,
it wasn't like what
Coss had gone through where it
was hard for him to get a job,
I had a job.
Right away.
You couldn't tell
anything, anything.
I was home for about one month.
I wasn't really working out.
Not really doing anything.
Just working, just
kind of doing my thing,
probably home for a month.
Me and my friend, he has
a barn, and in the barn
there was a bathroom.
I went in there because he
had cut himself or something.
We went in the medicine
cabinet, and there
was a bottle of Percocet
just waiting for us.
Take me, take me,
please, love me.
And we saw it and we
were like, oh, my god.
What is this?
Let's do this.
We thought it would be a good
idea to just do some Percocet
and that we could control it.
We know the consequences
of what could happen.
Yeah, we were dead wrong.
I'll probably say,
within a month
after that I was back
robbing banks again.
Because that's how
you support a habit.
Probably around that
time, actually, I
was doing cocaine again.
So now I'm doing heroin
and cocaine full fledged.
It was like a habit,
way worse than before.
And within three months
of that I robbed 19 banks.
And I thought I was going to do
it way better and way smarter.
I had different wigs,
and fake beards,
I made my skin complexion
different colors,
and tattoos in the face.
I had a lot of fun with
it, I'm not going to lie.
I was disguising myself with
all these weird different things
and I was getting away
with so many of them.
But my ego was just so
high up there and intense.
I would rob a bank, and
in a normal bank robbery
you get between 3,000 and
8,000 because you're only
hitting the register.
Like I said, I'm not
going in there with AK-47s
and hitting up the safe.
You've got to picture a bank
as a store that sells money,
so I'm getting
what's in the drawer.
I'm getting between
3,000 and 8,000.
I would take 3,000 or 5,000
and blow it all in one night.
We would get a party
bus and whatever
was left over and drugs
and food and everything,
and we would take a
party bus the city.
And I'd wake up in some random
hotel with just a shirt and one
sock on, not knowing
how I got there.
So it was crazy.
It was just madness
Eventually, I got caught.
And I got caught
fleeing the scene, which
never happens to anybody.
You never get caught
fleeing the scene.
But apparently someone
was following me outside
and saw the car I got into.
So now I get locked up.
And the last time
I got locked up--
I don't know if anybody's
ever heard of Suboxone?
Suboxone is like methadone,
but it's a better version of it
because you can't
actually do opiates
when you're on it,
whereas on methadone can.
So I was in a suboxone
program before I
got locked up, so
when I got locked up
I went through withdrawals
but not as bad as this time.
This time, like the
first week of it
I don't even remember
because I was so sick.
It was a completely
different experience.
I eventually get sentenced
to three and a half
to seven years, but
I owed parole time
from the last time I
was locked up because I
was only home for five months.
So I owe a year and 1/2 parole,
so now it's at three and a half
to nine years.
I get upstate and in
my mind I'm thinking,
something's got to change.
My family doesn't
want to talk to me.
The only person who was
talking to me was my mom.
She died in 2009,
about a year and a half
into me being upstate.
And we knew it we
knew it was going
to happen because she had
cancer, but the cancer, that
just hit.
She went in for an MRI, had an
x-ray or something like that
and they saw like a
small lump in her lung.
It was lung cancer.
She a cigarette smoker.
They saw this little
thing they're like,
it's probably nothing, but
let's do an MRI just in case.
It was lung cancer.
And it progressed so fast
and within a year she died.
It just happened.
And I was there to see her,
but when she came to my visits
I just kept seeing her,
every visit, deteriorating,
deteriorating.
And when that happened that
was like the bad turning point.
I was like, no, I gotta do--
like something has to change.
I have to change
my life right now.
And I had just completed,
it's a bullshit program,
but it's called ASET, Alcohol,
Substance Abuse Treatment.
It's a drug program that
they put everybody who's ever
even looked at a drug upstate.
It's a money thing,
but whatever.
I had just completed that
so I could pretty much
do any program I wanted.
So right after that
I joined college,
which is where I met my
buddy right here, Coss Marte.
So we meet--
SPEAKER: Shane, real quick just
so we have time for the Q&A.
I'm sure the audience
has some questions.
SHANE ENNOVER: Yes.
SPEAKER: Let's talk
about your association
and how the second
stint in prison
really geared you
up to understanding
how fitness is a recovery
tool for addicts.
Because I think
that's a huge point.
SHANE ENNOVER: Yes.
After I realized that
something had changed,
I started working
out a lot more.
I'm was actually trying to break
world records for pull-ups,
things like that.
I was really trying my
hardest to be a better person.
But now I'm going back to the
first time I got locked up,
I was realizing that
fitness is really
what was keeping me sober.
And I haven't heroin or cocaine
since the day I got locked up,
February 1, 2008.
So when I came home I
knew I wanted to give back
to the community somehow.
There was something,
just like how ConBody
is geared towards giving back
to the community of prisoners
and ex-convicts and
we only hire people,
what I did was started something
called Addicts Athletics.
And what Addicts
Athletics does is
we bring fitness
classes to people
recovering from drug addiction.
So I go into rehab centers,
I sponsor people much
like AA, Addicts Anonymous
or Alcoholics Anonymous,
they sponsor people.
I sponsor people by giving
them free training sessions,
free nutritional
plans, things like
that because I know fitness
is what's ultimately
going to keep someone sober.
It's purely physiological.
Our neurotransmitters
just fire up naturally.
It just does, that just happens.
Your dopamine, you
serotonin, things like that.
Now when you do drugs it's
making them fire up a lot more,
that's what's getting you high.
The minute you take that
away your body doesn't
know how to naturally make your
neural transmitters connect.
But when you start
working out, now they're
connecting a lot
more, a lot better,
to a much greater
degree than before.
So you'll feel better.
You won't feel like you need
to do the drugs anymore.
So this is what I started
because I really want
to give back to the community.
And we've held events like
fundraisers, things like that.
Real soon, we're trying
to finalize everything,
this place in the Lowe
East Side called Sucasa.
They're a part of Lower
East Side Service Center.
It's a residential
center, and I'll
be going in there training
the residents there, give them
free fitness classes for yoga,
working breathing techniques,
just all around counseling.
Yeah, that's pretty much it.
SPEAKER: Awesome, thank you.
So I'm going to open
it up to the floor.
If anyone has any
questions, feel
free to line up at
the mics located
on either side of the stage.
So, anyone have any
questions at this point?
AUDIENCE: I don't need a mic.
Great story, great program.
I'm an engineer, so I'm going
to ask the engineering question.
How do you scale it?
You're in the Lower East
Side, I live in the suburbs.
SHANE ENNOVER: OK
AUDIENCE: I want to
participate in the program.
So are you thinking about
franchising or something
like that, you know?
SHANE ENNOVER: We just started
this in November of last year,
so I'm still trying to figure
out an optimal business plan.
But for someone, just as
an individual that, say,
you live on Long Island, I
would try to figure out some way
that I can maybe come to you.
Or let's say, this place
I'm working at right now,
maybe I could work
a deal out with them
where you could come in there
and I would train there.
Or sometimes I would use
ConBody's facility in order
to train someone there.
And I would pay, Addicts
Athletics pays, for everything.
We pay for travel, we
pay if you need something
to eat afterwards
because you don't really
have too much money
because you're a recovering
addict, things like that.
We pay for pretty
much everything.
So if you needed some sort
of transportation or for me
to get out there,
whatever the case may be,
we would accommodate it.
AUDIENCE: I'm thinking more
like the ConBody piece, right?
You have a studio, you
get people in there,
you're associated with
it too, right yes?
SHANE ENNOVER: Yes,
yes, I'm a trainer.
Yeah
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
COSS MARTE: Yeah
so, lot of people
asked me, how am I
going to scale this?
How am I going to take
this to the next level?
We're actually opening up
three more locations this year.
In Midtown, we
actually landed a deal
with Saks Fifth Avenue,
where we're going to be,
opening up their wellness
center on May 1st.
And we're expanding to
Pittsburgh and in the Chelsea
area as well.
But a lot of people said,
just brick and mortar spaces,
that's a high overhead.
How is this going to
be really scalable?
So we came up with the idea
of doing ConBody live, which
is On Demand workout videos.
So you basically use
your own body weight,
we don't use any equipment,
you get a little nine
by six prison cell space
in your living room
and then you choose your
favorite ex-convict,
draw a platform to get
that prison body you always
desired for $5 a month.
AUDIENCE: Streaming?
Or is like the time when
you're all sort of--
COSS MARTE: It's On Demand now.
We launched it about, right now
it's almost been four months,
and we've had over 4,000 users.
4,000 subscribers
on our platform now.
They're from 22
different countries.
SHANE ENNOVER: You
said as an app?
We're working on something
like that right now, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then I could
bring it to the gym with me
because I never know what
to do when I'm by myself.
COSS MARTE: Or, you could just
go to the browser on Google
and put ConBody.com.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
COSS MARTE: Yeah, I know.
We're actually planning
to do a Kickstarter
in a couple of months.
We want to build a better
platform, and an app behind it.
So we're going to be launching
that probably in two months.
AUDIENCE: Then you can
help me [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: We can.
You guys can be
our newest client.
COSS MARTE: Yeah.
Let's do it.
Don't be scared we
only did seven years.
SPEAKER: And in solitary
confinement, only a couple.
SHANE ENNOVER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I just want to
say I know about you guys.
I've been working with Back
On My Feet, I'm a volunteer.
I know Marnie, and
I know Drescher.
Yeah.
I mean, what you
guys were saying.
I work with people uptown
that are transitioning out
of incarceration
and they're people,
to your point, Shane's point.
And also that substituting
exercise for addiction,
I mean I woke up from a
bender like 30 years ago,
started running and
haven't stopped.
And that gets to my question.
That was 30 years ago,
I'm in my mid 50s now.
Your program looks
really intense.
Is there ever any sense
of how you moderate that?
Like, burn out, to keep
doing this over time.
Have you seen that
with your program?
COSS MARTE: So it's a
multilevel workout program.
I was telling them,
my mom is 62 years old
and she works out four
times a week in my studio.
So it was made for everybody's
level, everybody sizes.
What we basically
do is tell people,
just try to keep up
with the trainer.
We push it to the next limit,
but you need to take a break,
you take a break
and get back in it.
So people really
progress themselves.
Burning out, what do you mean?
Burning out from the
trainer's point of view?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, long term
burning out, like fatigue.
COSS MARTE: I mean, everybody
is going to burn out.
I think people need to take a
break and really understand.
We do work outs
seven days a week,
but I personally take a break.
I do take a two day break and
work out five days a week,
just letting your
body recuperate.
In the studio we
basically work out
different parts of the
body every day of the week.
So we have Manic Monday,
which is a cardio day.
Tough Love Tuesday is isometric.
Lockdown Wednesdays,
which is lower body.
Workouts like Hardcore
Thursday, where we do
a lot of abs and core workouts.
And Full Body Friday
and Upper Body Saturday.
We change them every day of the
week so one part of the body
will feel better and
recuperate while you're
working on the other part.
SHANE ENNOVER: And also, just
piggybacking off all of that,
so we have ConBody and we have
a ConBody themed work out,
but each trainer kind of
brings their own style to it.
What you won't get from
Coss, you'll get from me.
What you won't get from me,
you'll get from [? Soldon. ?]
What you don't get from
[? Soldon ?] you get from
[? Ray. ?] Every trainer you'll
get some type of different
style from.
A lot of gyms don't have
that, a lot of studios
don't have that, which we do.
Which is really, really good.
AUDIENCE: So I haven't
yet been to your website
since this is my first
time learning about ConBody
and Addicts Athletics,
but do you have formerly
incarcerated individuals come
to work out you guys often?
Do they get special pricing?
Do you see that most of
your attendees are not?
What does that look like?
COSS MARTE: Our
customer base is mostly
females, 80%, young
professionals just like you.
So take out your
phone right now.
I was just kidding.
SPEAKER: I actually think
that's a funny point,
because something you
did with your business
when you were selling drugs is
you kind of located your target
market and that's
how you scaled.
And with ConBody you had
mentioned in a talk you did,
you came out and you
saw all of these women
in New York wearing yoga pants.
And that's how you also located
your target market, which
is a lot of what we in the
Google media department
really focus on.
So I think that is kind
of a funny focal point
of your business
and how you guys
changed the game doing that.
COSS MARTE: Yeah.
But formerly incarcerated
people come in and work out.
We do give them a discount.
We started this
scholarship program idea.
We've had people lose a
lot of weight from it.
Because I started getting
people around my neighborhood
that couldn't really afford it.
They'll go to Planet Fitness
for $20, $30 a month.
SHANE ENNOVER:
Which does nothing.
COSS MARTE: Which
they don't utilize
for the rest of the year.
But what we started
doing, I said,
give me your $30 and
I'll find a sponsor who's
going to pay $100.
Our unlimited classes
are $125 a month.
So we'll have somebody just
cover the rest of the cost,
and we'll send monthly updates
on that person's progression
and if they're losing weight,
if they're gaining more muscle.
So it's affordable and
accessible to anyone.
But to get that scholarship
we have a application
on our website and then
we screen the person
because a lot of
people hit us up
and they're trying
to save a dollar.
And I'm like, man, you live
on the Upper West Side.
You could afford
some of this shit.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a
ClassPass user, obviously.
So I'm always interested
in the ClassPass gym's
I go to, how you work with
ClassPass and other say,
Groupon, or services
that are providing deals.
$125 sounds like that's
what ClassPass also
used to have as their
unlimited option.
How do balance
pleasing the users
who might not be total full
time members of the gym,
but also want to be part
of it in some capacity.
How does that work out
as a ClassPass user?
Beneficial user for
you, or is it just
a way to acquire a customer
and then convert them into--
COSS MARTE: Both.
So ClassPass is a
great platform just
to get the word out there
and bring these people that
have never heard about
us and bring them down
to the Lower East Side.
Because a lot of people don't
come down there to work out.
Most of them stay in the
[? Flat Iron, ?] Chelsea area.
But we've had probably 100
people come through ClassPass
and convert as monthly members.
Which is a good conversion rate.
And ClassPass told us this
it was one of the biggest
conversion rates.
And financially, if
you want to fill up
a spot that's missing
from your personal studio
and there is a ClassPass
member coming in,
it's an extra dollar and a seat.
So why not fill that
space with any type
of money, currency coming in.
They don't give us a big
revenue cut behind each user,
but it's new people.
And even the people that
come through ClassPass
have a great relationship,
and some of them
are still using us
through ClassPass
and come on their own
time and help us out,
working side projects
like Addicts Athletics
and help them on the side like.
It's just a win-win situation.
SHANE ENNOVER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm in Bellmore.
I don't know what houses in Long
Island have AK-47s and jewelry,
but how is the neighborhood,
the Lower East Side
now, compared to
when you were there?
Do you think being there
now kind of wards off anyone
that is dealing to kids now
and they see a positive change?
From you?
I don't know how i was then.
COSS MARTE: Yeah, now it's
like completely gentrified.
It's probably one of the
hippest neighborhoods.
It's the best
neighborhood in the city.
AUDIENCE: Long
Island is pretty hip.
COSS MARTE: Before it
was a crazy neighborhood.
Like growing up,
every 10 steps that I
took I'd see a heroin needle.
In the building
that I grew up in
there used to be
drug lines going up
the building and buckets
coming down from the roof.
It was just a crazy, crazy
switch from what it is right
now.
Right now, you have
like a coffee shop
and hipsters all over the place.
But going back to
that neighborhood,
I've been approached by guys
who still are on the streets
when I first came home.
They were trying to get
me back into that world
and I told them, I don't even
know where to find a cigarette.
I was just completely
convinced that I was not
going back to that lifestyle.
I mean, a lot of people looked
at me crazy when I came home.
From making all this
money in the street
and then working out
in the park, and people
were like, yo, what the
hell is this guy doing?
And I was like, I'm building a
movement, do you want to join?
They were like, hell no.
And now when they see the gym
on the block they're like,
damn, you did it.
It's crazy.
It just gives people
hope and inspires people.
It makes people believers
that if you have an idea
it could be a reality.
SHANE ENNOVER: So, I'm
actually from Central Islip.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So a little further up.
SHANE ENNOVER: That
makes a lot of sense.
My drug dealer
lived in Amityville,
but on the [INAUDIBLE] border.
AUDIENCE: I don't
see this in Bellmore.
SHANE ENNOVER:
[INAUDIBLE], you do.
Pretty crazy out there.
SPEAKER: At this point,
we've taught people
how to deal drugs,
rob banks, and where
to find all your local dealers.
COSS MARTE: And quit Google.
SPEAKER: Well thank you
guys so much for coming.
I love your story and I hope
that we as a community can
continue sharing
it with everybody,
because it's just a
great way to make people
believe that you can.
COSS MARTE: Can I
mention one more thing?
SPEAKER: Of course.
COSS MARTE: As a
hustler, I want everybody
to take out their phones
right now, come on.
You've got a phone,
you work at Google,
you can afford this shit.
Let's go, take out your phone.
I just want you to click on
that app called Instagram
and just follow me.
ConBody, C-O-N-B-O-D-Y.
Maybe you will see us enough
on your stream that you'll be
inspired one day to come by.
There you go, you
know how to spell.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SHANE ENNOVER: And follow
Addicts Athletics, too.
COSS MARTE: I got you.
SPEAKER: To go all
the way down there--
COSS MARTE: I know.
I'll pay for your Uber.
I've got Uber pool.
No.
SPEAKER: I thought
you were actually
going to make everyone get up
and start doing the work out.
SHANE ENNOVER:
Well, that's next.
COSS MARTE: No, they've had a
long walk from the cafeteria.
SPEAKER: It is.
It's a big building.
COSS MARTE: We'll
give them a break.
SHANE ENNOVER: This
is a big building.
COSS MARTE: But thank you.
SPEAKER: Well,
thank you so much.
This is great and thank
you guys for coming.
SHANE ENNOVER: Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]